THE STATE OF WHATSAPP:
WhatsApp is one of the largest and most ubiquitous
social media platforms in the world.
With 2.7 billion monthly active users and
over 100 billion messages being sent every
single day, it’s no question that WhatsApp
is extremely successful from a market share
perspective, but the same cannot be said from
a financial perspective.
It’s been nearly 10 years since Facebook
bought WhatsApp but their revenue doesn’t
quite match up with their popularity.
In fact, it’s only now that WhatsApp is
even crossing the billion dollar mark in terms
of revenue.
Put another way, WhatApp only makes about
40 cents per user per year.
For perspective, YouTube has a similar user
count of 2.7 billion monthly active users,
but they pull in nearly $30 billion in revenue
per year or over $10 per user per year.
Even TikTok, a platform that’s not known
to have the most monetizable of demographics
is expected to pull in $13 billion this year.
But all of that is nothing in comparison to
the true king of social media monetization
and WhatsApp’s younger brother: Instagram.
In 2023, Instagram is expected to pull in
$50 billion or over $20 per user.
For those of you who have haven’t been keeping
track, that’s over 50 times more per user
per year that WhatsApp, and that’s not too
surprising.
The reality is that it’s quite hard to monetize
a free to use messaging platform, and believe
me, it’s not due to a lack of effort.
Over the years, Facebook has tried strategy
after strategy but all of them end up falling
flat because of the tricky game their trying
to play.
They don’t want to turn away users by making
the platform paid or by showing ads, but at
the same time, the platform does eventually
have to make money one way or another.
And this has pressure has been cranked up
to the max with the high interest and high
inflation environment where investors expect
companies to take a step back from growth
and really focus in on profitability.
So, what really is the long term financial
play with WhatsApp and will WhatsApp ever
be a lucrative business?
A LIFELONG STRUGGLE:
Taking a look back, WhatsApp’s struggle
to monetize can be traced all the way back
to day one in 2009.
From the very beginning, WhatsApp was kept
afloat by investors.
First, it was the founder’s friends from
Yahoo who agreed to invest $250,000 to get
the company going.
Then, it was $8 million from Sequoia and another
$50 million from Sequoia.
The only way that WhatsApp made money was
by charging users a dollar per year but that
was mainly just to cover the cost of verification
texts, so the actual cost of running the platform
and paying engineers had to come out of pocket.
WhatsApp was likely hoping that a lot of these
financial concerns could be addressed by scale
but scale only made things worse.
In fact, by the time that Facebook got involved,
WhatsApp had already reached 400 million active
users.
In the first half of 2014, however, these
400 million users only translated to a mere
$15.9 million worth of revenue while the bottom
line stood at, wait for it, -$232.5 million.
In other words, WhatsApp was burning nearly
half a billion per year with 400 million users.
If these losses were to scale to their current
size, WhatsApp would be burning over $3 billion
per year.
Clearly, the only way to make such a business
viable was to get the help of a tech giant
like Google or Facebook that could eat up
the losses, and that’s why WhatsApp would
eventually be sold to Facebook.
With the help of Facebook, you would think
that WhatsApp’s financial situation would
get bette but the exact opposite actually
happened.
WhatsApp no longer had to worry about staying
afloat and operationAtal but this simultaneously
made revenue generation even less of a concern.
In fact, Facebook not only neglected generating
more revenue with WhatsApp, but they straight
up undid revenue generation efforts that were
already in place.
FACEBOOK MAKES THINGS WORSE:
Kicking of 2016, Facebook would drop WhatsApp’s
annual $1 fee while also promising to stay
ad-free.
Why you ask?
Well, the official reasoning is that WhatsApp
wanted users who didn’t have a debit or
credit card to be able to stay in contact
with their family.
Reading between the lines though, WhatsApp
basically saw the $1 fee as a barrier to gaining
market share and utter market dominance, so
they dropped the fee.
This move was rather questionable though for
a few reasons.
First of all, it’s only $1 per year, and
I think that virtually everyone in the world
would agree that that’s a reasonable fee
for a messaging platform on a daily basis.
Second of all, avoiding the annual fee was
already quite easy, so users who really didn’t
want to or couldn’t pay didn’t have to.
And third of all, WhatsApp had already brought
the cost of messaging by hundreds of fold.
In fact, Forbes estimates that between 2012
and 2018, free messaging services like WhatsApp
and Skype had lost the telecommunications
industry a total of $386 billion.
At the time, such services had a combined
user count of about 2 billion.
So, according to this estimate, these services
were saving users on average $32 per year.
At that rate, even charging $10 per user per
year would’ve been reasonable much less
$1 per year and this would’ve completely
changed the trajectory of the business.
Even at $1 per year, WhatsApp would’ve crossed
the billion mark in terms of revenue way back
in 2015.
And if they eventually increment this to $2
per year and then $3 per year, it’s quite
possible that WhatsApp would’ve been pulling
in north of $10 billion per year in revenue
today.
But, Facebook would end up choosing growth
over everything else.
It’s possible that Facebook was thinking
that they could user data collection as a
way to monetize WhatsApp but this led to a
wholenother slew of issues.
Kicking it off in May of 2017, the European
commission would fine WhatsApp $122 million.
It turns out that WhatsApp was sharing user
data such as phone numbers with Facebook in
order to retarget these users with Facebok
ads.
The fine, however, was the least of Facebook’s
worries.
WhatsApp’s founders started to fear that
this was the new direction of WhatsApp, and
as a result, they would both quit within the
next year, leaving over a billion dollars
on the table to do so.
One of the founders would actually go on to
create a rival non profit messaging platform
and that’s what turned out to be Signal.
Atleast with the founders gone though, Facebook
could roll out shady monetization strategies
with less resistance or atleast that’s what
they thought until they got caught up in an
even bigger situation.
In 2018, Facebook would get caught up with
the Cambridge Analytica scandal, the largest
social media scandal of all time.
If you’re not familiar with the scandal,
Facebook was basically involved in a shady
data collection effort that may have influenced
the 2016 presidential election.
Facebook would end up having to pay a $5 billion
fine, the largest privacy related fine in
history by a full magnitude.
While Facebook was able to afford the fine,
their public reputation was permanently damaged.
And the last thing they wanted to do with
WhatsApp was create some sort of movement
against themselves by implementing some sort
of shady monetization strategy.
So, Facebook would lay low when it came to
WhatsApp monetization over the next few years
leading us to their current monetization crisis.
A DEAD END:
Facebook would eventually come out with a
rather creative avenue to monetize users indirectly
while also remaining ethical, and that avenue
was WhatsApp business.
WhatsApp business launched at the beginning
of 2018 as a way for businesses to leverage
the infrastructure of WhatsApp.
The way it works is that businesses can use
the WhatsApp business app or Whatsapp’s
business APIs in order to communicate with
customers on a familiar platform.
The first 1000 conversations every month are
free, but after that, businesses have to pay
for every conversation.
This is primarily how WhatsApp has been generating
revenue over the past couple of years, and
Zuckerberg is optimistic that WhatsApp business
is the future of WhatsApp, and it very well
could be.
WhatsApp Business could be the feature that
takes WhatsApp from what is at best a break
even business and turn it into a lucrative
busines.
But with that being said, this still neglects
monetizing the bread and butter of WhatsApp:
peer to peer communication, and to be honest,
I don’t think that will change.
The reality is that if Facebook wants to continue
growing WhatsApp’s user base, they cannot
make any sort of strong monetization effort.
Why?
Well, because the main competition for WhatApp
is now completely different.
When WhatsApp launched, the main competition
was regular old SMS texting and expensive
phone plans.
So, when WhatsApp offered a cheap alternative,
people ate it up.
Today, WhatsApp’s main competition is no
longer phone plans, their main competition
is Apple and more specifically iMessage.
Now, hearing that, you might be saying that
iPhone users are only a fraction of the global
smartphone market and that Android is the
dominant player.
But here’s the thing, western iPhone users
are the only people who don’t yet already
use WhatsApp.
Everywhere else is already literally 100%
saturated by WhatsApp and I’m not even exaggerating.
In Brazil, WhatsApp’s market share is 98.9%.
In India, their market share is 97.1%.
In Italy, it’s 97% and it’s the same way
basically everywhere else other than a few
exceptions.
These exceptions include Australia, Sweden,
the United States, Canada, and France where
WhatsApp’s marketshare hovers in the 30
to 40% range.
You know what else these countries have in
common?
Well, theses are the few countries around
the world where Apple dominates.
In fact, in the US, Apple straight up controls
the majority with 56% market share.
And this lines up almost exactly with WhatsApp’s
41% market share within the US.
And here’s the thing, Apple never needs
iMessage to be profitable.
I’m not even sure how you would measure
the profitability of iMessage.
From their perspective, iMessage is simply
one facet that sells their actual product
which is the iPhone experience.
So, they have 0 ulterior motives when it comes
to iMessage.
It’s in their best interest to keep iMessage
as great as possible for free, and that’s
what WhatsApp is having to go up against.
When it comes to privacy centric iPhone users,
WhatsApp’s association with Facebook itself
takes them down a peg.
If you combine this with some sort of pay
wall or shady monetization strategy, you basically
give up all chances of converting these customers.
But let’s even forget about acquiring new
users.
With Android bleeding market share globally,
WhatsApp has to make sure that they don’t
end up bleeding users to iMessage which all
leaves WhatsApp in a rather sticky situation.
They’ve sacrificed revenue and profit over
the past decade just so that they can maximize
market share and eventually monetize.
But, now that they’re on the other side,
it turns out that they have to continue this
arrangement if they want to protect their
market share.
And instead of monetizing that main consumer
use of their platform, they’re having to
monetize business use of their platform.
But hey, maybe that’s not such a bad thing.
Unlike Facebook as a whole which very much
got bloated, WhatsApp has always been a pretty
lean business probably because WhatsApp never
generated all that much revenue.
In fact, WhatsApp only needed 50 engineers
to reach 900 million users.
So, it’s likely that the WhatsApp team is
still only in the low triple digits.
So, WhatsApp doesn't need to make billions
and billions of dollars to remain self sustainable
or worth pursuing.
WhatsApp may never become a cash cow for Meta,
but that doesn’t stop WhatsApp from carrying
the Meta name, keeping the company relevant,
and earning them some good will which is definitely
valuable.
Clearly, Facebook has yet to figure out how
to monetize WhatsApp’s massive user base,
but something that they have figured out is
how to monetize their $61 billion cash reserves
with the help of high yielding treasury bills
and bonds.
With historically high interest rates, the
appeal bills and bonds is the higher than
ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t
really adapted with the times.
They still expect people to use clunky bond
tables, scroll through long overwhleming lists,
and even use virtual keyboards till recently.
And that’s why we created our own modern
bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience
and the ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust, so that you too
can lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety.
Every Silo account is insured by $500,000
in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
insurnace.
Also, all funds deposited on the platform
will be maintained by our trusted custodian,
Interactive Brokers, who has experience managing
$373 billion worth of assets over the past
45 years.
So, if you’re looking for a modern way to
invest in bonds, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below.
One social media that actually secretly makes
a bunch of money is LinkedIn.
Check out this video to learn more.